tonight allows people a release for all
the hatred and violence if they keep up
inside them this won't bring him back
it won't make you feel any better thank
you it is a night that is defining our
country citizens this will be a
tradition we celebrate every year join
the first purge how do you think says
always see tonight people are now
calling this controversial experiment of
legalized crime the purge you and Isaiah
just stay with me doing the purge oh
we're gonna be fine on out we are here
with dr. main up Dale she came up with
this experiment is the purge a political
device it is a psychological one if we
want to save our country we must release
all our anger in one night
tonight we'll see the good and evil in
everyone this is your emergency
broadcast system announcing the
commencement of the first purge our
neighborhood is under siege from a
government he doesn't give a [ __ ] about
any of us
of crime including murder will be legal
for 12 hours there's a lot of good
people out there who we gonna have to
protect you all emergency services will
be suspended we gotta be prepared for
anything
your government thanks you for your
participation parties you predicted a
much higher level of participation human
nature does not obey the laws of
politics
they all ex-military some funky going
down deep you're sending soldiers into
the island disguised as citizens this
country needs for the store
no one's coming to help us after tonight
nothing will ever be the same again they
forgot about one thing they forgot about
us what have I done
a strong
just remember all the good the purge
does
you